Usa la fórmula cuadrática
para resolver la ecuación
0 es igual a -7q cuadrada más 2q más 9,
y bueno la fórmula cuadrática,
nos sirve para solucionar
ecuaciones de la forma
ax cuadrada más bx más "c" igual a 0,
ó en su dado caso
0 igual a ax cuadrada más bx más "c",
a ax cuadrada más bx más "c",
y esta es la ecuación cuadrática general
en la cual casi siempre se usa
la variable "x" para resolverla
pero, también
podemos usar cualquier otra letra.
De hecho en esta ocasión
vamos a usar "q",
y aunque de una manera muy general
las soluciones se expresan en términos de "x",
también la fórmula cuadrática nos dice
que las soluciones se ven de la siguiente manera,
"x" es igual a -"b"
más menos la raíz cuadrada
de "b" cuadrada menos 4ac,
todo esto dividido entre 2a,
todo esto entre 2a.
Y estas son las soluciones de la ecuación cuadrática usando la fórmula cuadrática.
Pero bueno todo esto,
está expresado en la variable "x",
date cuenta que en esta ocasión las soluciones
de esta ecuación cuadrática, dependen de "q",
lo podremos poner "x"
pero también "q" nos sirve,
y por lo tanto, voy a decir que éste,
el coeficiente que está al lado
del término que está elevado al cuadrado,
éste de aquí, va a ser "a",
éste de aquí es "a".
Éste,
que es el término que está al lado
de la "q" elevada a la primera potencia,
a este le voy a decir que es "b",
es el que está al lado de la primera potencia,
y por último éste,
que es el coeficiente constante
a este le voy a llamar "c",
éste de aquí va a ser "c"
y entonces lo único que hay que hacer
es aplicar esta fórmula cuadrática para "q"
¿y qué nos va a quedar?.
Bueno ,vamos a decir que "q" es igual a "b"
pero "b" en esta ocasión vale 2,
entonces - 2 más menos,
más menos la raíz cuadrada.
Esta fórmula
sería muy buena que te la aprendieras
de "b" cuadrada,
es decir, de 2 elevado al cuadrado
menos 4 veces ac
menos 4 veces
"a", pero "a" vale -7,
entonces menos 4 veces -7
por "c" pero, "c" vale 9,
por lo tanto a esto hay que multiplicarlo
por lo que vale "c",
por 9,
y a todo esto,
a todo esto de aquí,
hay que dividirlo entre 2 veces "a"
pero, "a" vale "c" menos 7,
entonces todo esto
entre 2 por -7,
y bueno lo único que hay que hacer
es resolver esta ecuación,
¿y qué me va a quedar?
Esto es igual a -2,
más menos la raíz cuadrada
¿De quién?
2 al cuadrado es 4
y después me queda,
menos por menos me da más
por más, me da más,
más
7 por 4 es 28, por 9
¿Cuánto es 28 por 9?
Vamos a hacerlo aquí.
28 lo voy a multiplicar por 9
y dice
9 por 8, 72
y llevamos 7
9 por 2,
18 más 7
252 ¡Perfecto!
Pongámoslo aquí,
más 252
y a todo esto,
todo esto
hay que dividirlo entre 2 por -7,
lo cual me da -14,
y bueno pues vamos a sumar los 2 números que están adentro de la raíz,
y me queda que esto es igual a -2,
más menos la raíz cuadrada,
de 4 más 252
lo cual me da 256
y a esto lo voy a dividir entre -14.
¡Muy bien! Pero
¿Cuánto es la raíz cuadrada de 256?
Bueno pues la raíz cuadrada de 256
es 16,
todo esto se va a 16,
puedes tú calcularlo,
16 al cuadrado es 256
por lo tanto, vamos a sustituirlo,
pero aquí
hay un paso muy importante.
Te das cuenta que tengo más menos,
la raíz cuadrada de 256,
esto quiere decir
que tengo dos posibles soluciones.
La primera solución
se vería algo así -2 más 16
entre -14,
me estoy tomando el primer signo
que es el signo de más,
o en su dado caso,
la otra solución se puede ver como -2 menos 16
entre -14,
y esto es muy importante,
porque estamos tomando
dos soluciones,
este signo de más me está marcando,
este más que yo tengo aquí,
y por otra parte este menos que está aquí
es justo este mismo menos que estoy poniendo aquí.
La solución se divide en 2,
en una solución con signo positivo
y de otra solución con signo negativo,
y pues,
¿cuánto es esto?
Bueno pues "q" entonces
va a ser igual a,
-2 más 16,
me da 14 positivo,
14 entre 14 negativo
me da -1.
Esta es mi primer solución.
La otra solución es la siguiente
-2 menos 16,
esto es lo mismo que -18,
entre -14 y
¿Cuánto es esto?
-18 lo puedo sacar mitad
y me da 9,
y date cuenta que menos entre menos se va,
menos entre menos es más
y después 14 le puedo sacar mitad,
y me da 7,
por lo tanto,
en mi otra solución son 9/7,
y ya tengo mis 2 raíces para esta ecuación cuadrática,
mis 2 valores de "q" que cumplen
que al ponerse en esta ecuación cuadrática,
me dan de solución igual a 0.
Son mis soluciones de esta ecuación cuadrática
utilizando la fórmula cuadrática
y de hecho lo podemos comprobar,
si ponemos este valor
y lo sustituimos aquí en el valor de "q"
y ponemos este valor después
y  los sustituimos aquí también
en este valor de "q",
nos tiene que dar 0.
Y es más vamos a hacerlo para el primero,
para que veas que en efecto nos sale este resultado.
Si yo pusiera -1 me quedaría,
-7 que multiplica a -1 elevado al cuadrado,
más 2 que a su vez multiplica -1 más 9
¿y cuánto es esto?
Pues bueno -1 elevado al cuadrado pues esto es lo mismo que 1,
-7 por 1 me da -7
2 por -1 me da -2,
-7 menos 2 me da -9,
más 9 me da 0,
y de hecho se te queda de tarea,
y sería muy bueno,
que tú probaras que también 9/7
es la otra raíz
de esta ecuación cuadrática.